thomas massey a member of congress joins
us with his guest
congressman i really appreciate your
coming on tonight so
clearly it's not about violence you go
to watch you work in washington the city
is consumed by violence the crime rate's
gone up ever since the george floyd riot
started and nobody cares
police are nowhere to be found what are
these troops really about do you think
that's a good question and before i
touch that i want to remind people that
what i'm about to say is not meant to be
critical of the troops
or of the capitol hill police but what
you know what people might be mistaking
mistakenly
thinking is going on here is that
congress is doing the two things that
they do well
which is to do nothing and then to
overreact to
to basically not provide for protection
and then to show up with 26 000 troops
but that is not what's going on here
it's much more insidious than that
they are using these soldiers as a
pretext for three things in washington
dc
right now number one they've promised
that these soldiers will be there during
the impeachment trial
you see the impeachment trial in the
senate is unconstitutional
but unless they give you the impression
that donald trump created
something that's still going on then
there's no reason to have an impeachment
trial so they want the soldiers there
for that
the other thing that's going on is some
of my democratic colleagues want to
expel
republican members in the house and the
senate for merely objecting to things on
the house floor
they're saying they're seditionists and
so by projecting this
image of the capital under siege by
quote domestic
terrorists they're keeping that agenda
alive but the most insidious thing that
they're
the reason that they have these soldiers
here tucker is
is that they want to pass new laws that
will
invade your privacy confiscate your guns
in the name of domestic terrorism
they're trying to project
this image and my colleagues aren't
stupid they know that images are more
powerful than any words they could say
on the senate floor or the house floor
they're trying to project an image that
we are under siege that the country is
under siege
from an ever-present danger of domestic
terrorism
but here's what's ridiculous their
definition of domestic terrorism
is so broad now that it includes the
actual
guardsmen who are there to protect them
my colleagues have whipped themselves
into a state of fear and paranoia
very quickly i i know a lot of your
colleagues in the republican conference
are
for which were all for the troops but
they want to send them to you know
invade iran or whatever
why has nobody stood up and made the
obvious point this is about political
power the troops in our
country's capital please make them leave
immediately
why aren't republicans saying that
well this may be the next forever war
look 911
was used as the pretext to grab civil
liberties
and to deploy troops around the globe
when they're still not back
and they do need to come back but now
we've got is more troops deployed
in our nation's capital than we do those
two countries
so yep this is grotesque and i
appreciate
you finding a member of congress to say
this as clearly as you did was not easy
and so i'm grateful that you came to say
what you said
congressman massey thank you thomas
massey of kentucky thank you tucker